so today I want to talk about the
Mandelbrot set but I want to so there's
so many videos and websites and Java
applets and all of these things where
you can see the beauty of the Mandelbrot
set and this really nice fractal picture
and you can zoom in and see all the
interesting things
[Music]
what I want to talk about is what is
this object so what is the picture a
picture of why do we care about this
picture other than just its intrinsic
sort of appeal and so just to generally
talk about the way that maybe
mathematicians will look at the
Mandelbrot set
[Music]
the first thing we need to understand is
that this entire thing is happening in
the world of complex numbers okay so if
you remember complex numbers the complex
planes the way that we view this is that
we have two axes and we plot on this
plane numbers of the form say a plus bi
and here these two things are real
numbers and I is a symbol that means
that I squared is equal to minus one
okay so most people are familiar with
this but just a reminder it's a
convenience in some sense but there's
also a lot of useful information in this
representation so for example one thing
that's very natural to look at is if I
plot some complex number say a plus bi
okay maybe this is something like you
know 3 plus 2i something like that then
one sort of natural quantity associated
with this thing is the distance from
this point to the center point of the
plane and so this distance which we call
the magnitude of the complex number it
really has some some inherent
mathematical properties that we really
care about and so the fact that this is
so easy to visualize in the complex
plane and you can also visualize like
addition of complex numbers and
subtraction and so on in this plane and
a very geometric way is really helpful
[Music]
so how do we get to the Mandelbrot set
from here so here's sort of just the
naive definition let's take a complex
number C and let's associate to this
complex number the following function so
this is a function which takes as an
input some complex number Z and outputs
Z squared plus C so I'm thinking of this
complex number as being associated to
this function and we what we're
interested in is the behavior of 0 under
iteration so by iteration of FC I mean
what happens when I take 0 and I plug it
into this function and then I keep doing
that to the results so for example if
we're looking at F 1 of Z well F 1 of 0
is equal to 0 plus 1 which is 1 F 1 of 1
so now I apply it to the answer that I
got right this is 1 plus 1 which is 2 F
1 of the previous thing which was 2 is 2
squared plus 1 which is 5 F 1 of 5 is 5
squared plus 1 which is 26 and so on so
that's what I mean about the behavior of
0 under iteration for a particular value
of C now what the Mandelbrot set is
concerned with is what happens to the
size of these numbers and by size I mean
exactly what we were talking about
before about the distance from the
number in the complex plane to this
point zero okay so it turns out there's
two options for a function f C of Z
defined to be Z squared plus C the first
option is that the distance from 0 of
the sequence we get gets arbitrarily
large I mean just blows up means it
blows up it gets as large as you want it
to be ok so this is what people mean
when they say that the iterates go to
infinity okay they mean not necessarily
that ok they look like real numbers or
integers or something like this but that
the size of the number in this sense
goes to infinity the other thing that
can happen is that the distance is
bounded the size is bounded so and in
fact you can say that it
it gets larger than two so you have this
sort of dichotomy where only one of two
things can happen if you give me a
complex number C and I start iterating
zero under that function Z squared plus
C either the distance of the iterates to
zero in this complex plane gets really
large for all of them so you can't
bounce back and forth right gets really
large for all of them or it stays close
to zero within 2 of 0 so for example to
illustrate these two cases we wrote down
already a few iterates under Z squared
plus 1 of 0 and as you can see their
size is growing and in particular we've
got some things that are further from
zero than two is and so this C equals 1
is case one but there's another
possibility so let's look at well a good
contrast maybe would be Z squared minus
1 although this might be a little
misleading so if we look at say 0 and we
start applying this function well F
minus 1 of 0 that's 0 minus 1 which is
minus 1 if we plug in minus 1 to that
function we have minus 1 squared which
is 1 which is 0 oh wait okay but we know
what happens to 0 right it goes back to
minus 1 so these iterates just alternate
between minus 1 and 0 and so in
particularly they never get large right
so that's an example of case 2 so the
definition of the Mandelbrot set then
one definition of the Mandelbrot set
which we usually call M is the set of C
complex numbers C for which case two
holds and I'm kind of all over the place
here so let's be clear case two so in
other words if I look at the function
represented by this complex number if I
look at Z squared plus C and I start
iterating 0 under that function
everything remains bounded it's the guys
that don't blow up that's right it's the
guys that don't blow up instead of the
ones that do and this is also in case
you're curious how these pictures are
always generated so if you want to
figure out to draw a picture whether C
is in the Mandelbrot set or not
well you just start iterating 0 under Z
squared plus C and if it takes a long
time
to get big then you can give it one
color if it gets big really quickly you
can give it a different color and that's
how you get these shadings I'll point
out here that everything that's in the
Mandelbrot set has to be within distance
- of the center right because of exactly
this case - thing that I said that once
your iterate is larger than - you're
you're out of the picture so the inside
of this thing let's fill this in here
this is what's known as the Mandelbrot
set so let's look at our examples right
so we had two examples we had C equals
one and we had C equals minus 1 so minus
1 just right here is indeed inside the
Mandelbrot set one is right here and
it's outside let me take the easiest
example inside of there so if we look at
0 right C equals 0 and we start
iterating well what is the function
associated to C equals 0 f 0 of Z is Z
squared okay so let's start iterating 0
well 0 squared is 0 so no matter how
many times we apply the function we just
stay at 0 so you're in the club so
you're in the club that's right
but if we take like say some small
number here it's a little hard to
compute without taking a real number so
I apologize but if we take something
like you know 1 over 8 something like
that if we start iterating so the first
iterate is 1/8 and then you start adding
things under iteration but but it's
never enough to get you outside of that
disk of radius 2 these guys are blowing
up that's right these ones are not
blowing up that's right that's where
things are interesting right where you
go from blowing up to not blowing up
it's is dynamically interesting and just
sort of like loosely speaking the reason
why is that you can't predict what's
going to happen if you change C a little
bit right so if I have some C on the
boundary here so it so happens that 1/4
is on the boundary if I move that C
around by a little bit anything can
happen right you might have your orbit
blow up you might have it not blow up
and so you can't predict what happens
when you move your C around a little bit
and that's why it's interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
these separate disconnected pieces and
so it turns out that another way you
could define the Mandelbrot set is by
which of these two behaviors you get
when you draw the filled Julia set for Z
squared plus C do you get kind of one
piece one blob or do you get a bunch of
disconnected pieces so if you get one
piece one blob you're in the Mandelbrot
set